people would rather stay poor than risk
doing something entrepreneurial people
are so afraid to put themselves out
there if you do anything in life people
are going to laugh at you they'll call
you a scammer they'll tell you that
you're not good enough people are so
afraid of being labeled these things and
they would literally rather stay poor
they would rather not feed their parents
help their parents than be laughed at
this is a loser mentality you have to
consider all the noise around you as
just that noise imagine it as a
different language imagine it as Russian
I don't speak Russian so I don't know
what all of that means you say it but I
don't hear it like I can't internalize
it so you have to be laser focus you
need tunnel vision understand what is
your goal where do you want to get to
everything else is just noise and it
doesn't matter